the tech industry likes to portray
itself as a beacon of progress all ping
pong tables and immaculate gadgets but
it's got a problem with sexism
aleem has worked in tech for seven years
I've been asked before to come and look
pretty in a meeting which I enjoyed also
been told to wear a bit more makeup
I've been asked how old I am
whether I'm married thinking of having
any kids anytime soon
she says sexism in technology is worse
than in other sectors if you look at
more female dominated industries it's
normal that women go on maternity leave
you shouldn't feel bad about getting
married and wanting to have kids which
is what happens in the tech industry
unfortunately Skye worked with online
magazine Nepal to poll its female
readers who work in tech about their
experiences 39 percent of those women
said they've been denied a significant
opportunity at work because of their
gender 15 percent said they've been
asked about their marital status in a
job interview and 14 percent have been
asked about their intention to have
children 39 percent also said their
organization is biased towards hiring
men over women for technical or senior
roles sex doesn't get scrutinized like
finance does because you know baddies
work in finance everybody of those
baddies work in finance where text young
it's cool it's hip it's still why it's
still male and that I don't think we've
seen that change really all female
officers like the pools are part of the
solution tech UK is the trade body for
all technology companies in this country
the tech industry is being proactive in
pocket so I would say there's pinpricks
of ecstasy which is that you know we are
doing quite a lot a lot of its headlines
I would I would reinforce the fact that
it's the small stuff that makes a
difference and that means it's personal
and that means it's all of our
responsibility to do to make the 2
million meter shifts that going to make
a difference
those millimeters might well eventually
add up but it's a long way to go
Tom Cheshire Sky News